Please.
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
Abbas.
Islam.
[Silence]
This narration is on the authority of
he's one of the
a companion
in the
Islamic literature when the scholars
say the word companion companion
sahhabi. Well, there's very particular
criteria for that. What is a companion?
A companion
is anyone who met the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam
as a believer and died upon that belief.
Anyone who met the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam as a believer and died a
Muslim. So if they meet him
and then die a non-Muslim, this is not a
companion. If they believe in him but
never meet him or if they meet him as a
non-Muslim and then later accept Islam
but never meet him again, they're not a
companion.
A companion is someone who meets him as
a believer and dies upon Islam. What is
a tabir? A tabir
is anyone
who is a companion of the companions.
They are the generation that are the
students the companions of the
companions
and
are the students of the students of the
companions. Why is this important? Why
these three generations?
Because the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam mentioned that these first
three generations
are the best generations
of his
is one of the students of Ib Abbass. He
was the muti of Mecca
is responsible for narrating much of
Ab's
says here
he was with Abbass once and Abbas said
to him would you me to show you
someone who is a person of the people of
paradise walking on this earth with us
currently.
I said, "Of course."
[Silence]
He said, "This woman here," and he
describes her as this black woman.
Well, this isn't because black or white
has anything to do with the ruling. This
isn't because black or white or race of
a person has anything to do with a
person's iman or belief. The reason he
says this and you'll find this in some
narrations
is that in the days of Jahya,
this was considered a
this was considered a a lower cast of
people, a lower race. And so it wouldn't
be imagined that people that didn't come
from the most, you know, most
illustrious
backgrounds and people that would
come from a lower cast as they
would believe or a lower race in their
belief. there would be a person of
paradise or there would be a person that
is a companion or someone that has any
high standing in the community.
However, the first thing the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam did in the
conquest of Mecca is that he had
climb on top of the make
and that image changed the entire course
of history. That image changed what
people saw in each other and what people
it completely changed the scales and the
metrics for a person of authority, a
person of lofty and esteem and and
lofty standing and a person who is
not of high esteem. And so he says this
woman came to the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam and said I have fits and
when I'm having these fits
because of you know I'm lost control
of my body my clothes start to
come off and parts of my body start to
become exposed.
So make dua to Allah that these things
can stop. What are these fits? It's
unclear whether this was some kind of
possession or whether this was fits
of you know seizures or some kind of
neurological issue. The point is is that
she would have these fits and as she is
shaking or losing control of her body
parts of her body would become
exposed. And so she asked him for two
things to make dua that she's healed
from these fits and second that she is
not exposed
in this way. And so the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam said
and so he gave her an option. He said if
you if you want
you can choose to be patient with what
Allah has chosen to decree upon you and
for you is paradise if you are patient
through this
or
if you choose I can make dua and Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala will cure you or he
will relieve this
and so she said,
she said, "No, well then in that case I
will be patient."
She said, "But I become exposed. My body
becomes exposed when I'm having these
fits. Please make dua for me that when I
have these fits, I at least do not
become exposed."
And so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
then made dua for her to no longer
become exposed. The question is why the
ultimatum? Why the choice? Why not make
dua and make this go away and have have
secured paradise?
Well, the answer is simple. You cannot
get to paradise or get to the high
places of paradise without difficulty.
And what Allah has chosen for you is
better than what you choose for
yourself. This here seems a
nuisance in your life. It may be your
soul ticket to paradise and you're going
to pray for it to go away. And so you
can either remain steadfast and patient
with what Allah has given you because if
this isn't your hardship, some other
hardship will take its place. And if
every time a hardship comes, we're going
to have it prayed away. Then at what
point are we going to rise in our esteem
and levels? We've already heard the
prophet sallall.aii
tell us
that great reward comes with great
difficulty. This narration has been
collected by
Alhamdulillah.